we're here at the tcl chinese theater on  historic hollywood boulevard otherwise  known as the walk of fame  so my grandfather his name is john  barrymore he had a sister and a brother  named ethel and lionel and they were  known as the barrymores and he was also  known as the great profile or as he  called it profile he actually put his  face in the cement and it's the only one  here that has it but because he was  known for his profile which i'm lucky  enough to have inherited  i am  gonna do something i always do when i  come here  and  sometimes our family  isn't here although we didn't get to be  together  i've taken on the responsibility to keep  carrying out their name  and keep it alive  so this tiny piece of cement is a way to  stay close to him and it means a lot to  me  it's as close as i'm going to get to him  [Music]